hi there steve here i hope you can hear
me above the din of some of the
construction equipment that's going on
here i'm standing by the steps to the
arts building at mcgill university of
course i'm in montreal for the polyglot
the long fest
gathering of polyglots and people who
are interested in languages here in
montreal but i decided to visit mcgill
because 55 years ago more or less around
this time say a month or so later i
enrolled mcgill university and i had to
come up these steps to
decide which courses i was going to take
uh so that's 55 years ago by the way
it's quite sunny so i have a hat that i
picked up in ukraine i love ukraine
because after all yesterday i believe
was the uh
26th
sort of independence the anniversary of
uh ukrainian independence so i salute
any ukrainians lava ukrainian
uh my granddaughter is going to be 20
years old tomorrow
so that's another milestone
and i took the opportunity here to visit
bookstores to see what they have in the
way of language learning books
so the only bookstore that was nearby
was one where they had material for sort
of immigrant learners
and they had these grammar books and a
series of them very and the books sort
of ranged in price from 19 to 50 dollars
the lady explained that for a three
month
sort of semester the average learner
would spend 90 bucks just on textbooks i
have no idea what the cost of the class
is she says it's done in conjunction
with a language lab
i don't even know why people use
language labs i have my language lab
right now i'm using it to film this
video
there's so much in the way of resources
available why people bother with all the
stuff i don't know i was looking for
their main bookstore because i remember
when i was in
stanford in palo alto california
the books there for uh learning italian
and russian were like 150 200 a book
again i don't know what the results are
of those books how well people do
certainly our experience in canada is
for example with the immigrants that
what the immigrant does outside the
classroom is much more important than
what happens inside the classroom and
this is because our learning uh of
languages is like so much so much of our
learning we learn from experience so
people who have a lot of experience with
the language the brain is dealing with
this language and finding ways to to
manage the language creating new
synapses in the brain the brain changes
all the time
[Music]
whether formal instruction has the same
effect on our brain
personally i doubt
tomorrow
and over the next three days i want to
get into the discussion with some of the
other polyglots over over this you know
i was doing some reading about the brain
and of course the brain changes all the
time as we learn it's not only the brain
that changes science changes so
scientists used to believe that our
brains were fixed uh at birth almost
uh and then they discovered that there
is this uh
neural plasticity that the brain keeps
changing
but that it firms up let's say in
childhood and then they describe this
this process of pruning unnecessary
synapses and focusing on those synapses
that matter and so that would suggest
that
once uh sort of unnecessary synapses
have been pruned then unless you have
been using synapses that relate say to
language learning or being exposed to
other languages
then you might be less good at learning
languages
but then they discovered that in fact
the pruning of synapses happens again at
adolescence at puberty and now they
discover that it continues up to uh your
20s
so but obviously the earlier you can get
the brain used to dealing with other
languages better but is this achieved
this developing the ability to deal with
other languages is it is achieved more
through exposure to the language
enjoyable exposure to the language or
through some deliberate instruction
where you have tests and you fail in the
tests and you develop
a certain fear of getting things wrong
and fear of making mistakes and so forth
i suspect that a proper program of
simply exposing people to things that
matter to them in the language crashes
meaningful content meaningful content is
going to be more effective in training
the brain and developing those neural
connections that will enable people to
to be good language learners anyway
those are some of the uh themes that uh
that i want to get into
i believe i mean i'm certainly learning
languages at the age of 70. my brain is
still learning
yesterday i or was it yeah it was
yesterday i i looked up you know i
subscribed i took about a three-day pass
on the sort of rent-a-bike system here
in montreal
got the instructions on how to use it on
the internet went to the station to pick
up my bike and i couldn't figure out how
to get a bike ended up having to phone
them three times finally i gave up i
refunded had my three day pass refunded
bought a one day pass that worked
then i went to my destination but i went
by the wrong route
but i'm learning so now i know how to
negotiate a bike from the station i know
the best route to go there again and so
we're always experiencing things and as
we experience these things we learn
sometimes deliberate instruction
if we haven't already experienced these
things
the deliberate instruction explanation
manual is very hard for the brain to
deal with so pleasurable exposure again
i'm beating on a on a
very uh
you know same old drum again
but stephen krashen is going to be here
who to my mind is the leading
explainer of how we learn and some truly
outstanding polyglots and i'm going to
be asking them a lot of questions how
many of them were exposed to a lot of
languages as children how many of them
grew up in a monolingual family and then
subsequently became polyglots when how
and so forth so i'm looking forward to
learning a lot and
that's all for today thanks for
listening bye for now
[Music]
you